[Music]
welcome to session number 29 and the
speculative fiction they're all old
pants I don't to go through all the
usual sewing and dance about what we do
today we have Arthur Clark one of the
great 20th century science fiction
authors that and I picked four books in
particular that they don't they don't
have the same narrative universe in the
sense of continuity between them but
they all have fairly similar themes and
they also seem like fairly easy ones to
get your hands on compared to some of
his other books so I thought you know we
begin with you know the usual way
talking about a biography a bit a few
remarks and then talking about his world
building and I've got six philosophical
themes picked out but I think you guys
will probably be bringing some to the
table as well one that I've given you a
handout on is laws as three laws of as
three types of mystery they thought
would be interesting and then I wanted
to talk about the aliens as rational
beings how the third theme is like the
variety of humans standpoints and how we
work these out politically forth his
religion and Clark's views on that he
has some very clear views he's
essentially a humanist his notion of
moral or ethical development which runs
not just through his novels but through
all his engagements in his life and then
you know we've all seen 2001 now
remember how going nuts so I thought
technology robots artificial
intelligence these are all themes that
you know we've talked about quite a lot
and you know Clark is not that far from
us in terms of time in a way because he
he only died in 2008 he was still
thinking quite a bit about the human
future at that time he had to revise
some of his estimates about what the
happen he gave me a farewell address his
90th birthday the year before he died in
December he recorded a greeting to
friends around the world and three he
expressed three wishes and I thought
this would be kind of interesting to
start with the third wish was actually
about Sri Lanka and it's it's continual
conflict that was going down he said
that I've been living in Sri Lanka for
50 years half that time I've been a
Santa witness of a bitter conflict that
divides my adopted country I really want
to see lasting peace established in Sri
Lanka as soon as possible so that was
one thing the other two things that he
brought up one had to do with you might
call it energy policy he said I would
like to see us kick our current
addiction to women adopt clean energy
sources climate change has now added a
new sense of urgency our civilisation
depends on energy but we can't allow oil
and coal to slowly bake our planet and
you know what there's a lot of debate
about this but that one thing is quite
clear that we're not whatever resources
we use for fossil fuels we're not going
to be able to just use them indefinitely
because there it takes a long time to
make them and you know we have great
reserves that we keep finding but we're
gonna run out sooner or later so what
are we going to do eventually if we
think long term he was somebody who
listened long term and then the other
thing that he said which i think is a
good lead-in to talking about some of
the themes that we have so I would like
to see some evidence of extraterrestrial
life I've always believed we're not
alone in the universe
but we're still awaiting for et to call
us or give us some kind of sign I we
have no way of guessing when this might
happen
I hope sooner than later and in some of
the novels that we are looking at the
extraterrestrials did reach out and show
up here and give us
a sign so I thought that would you know
be an interesting thing to begin with
and what let's so let's talk about his
biography and also you guys have any
objections to jumping right into that
that seems you know no worthy or
whatever that he says just before he
died that there was hearty evidence that
the aliens yeah how does that interplay
with his credible fiction I mean I mean
the credibility of this fiction in his
own mind you know I mean I I just think
that science fiction writers or anybody
read about a an alternative future
whatever you call it that has an
inherent belief that there's you know
another reality and they believe it
exists yeah I mean they're writing about
they're creating it they don't need sort
of what is it really where is it the
evidence yet he's saying in the in the
end I mean yeah you know there's the
both sides I mean yeah in the end say I
wish the hard evidence was there but
don't disbelieve what I wrote I think
part of it is that the he wanted to see
certain transformations take place and
then his his books depict them as sort
of possibilities for the even race like
in this one you know the earth is
actually destroyed before that they send
out these seed colonies and most of them
are getting rid of any sort of like
religious tax they they sort of put a
hard stop on that and all the literature
that goes with it
for our determinant reason and then with
like 2001 of course you have the aliens
coming in you don't have any aliens you
said there's [ __ ] and then with
childhoods end you have the aliens
showing up and you know making making
peace on earth but it takes 15 years
before the aliens could actually show
their forms so I think one of the
reasons I wanted to see it's not to say
he'd be vindicated it's rather he wanted
to see catalysts leading to the kinds of
social transformation that he thinks is
necessary for human beings to continue
to exist the other thing I want to bring
up I actually have us like in a
different section but there's a great
quote about healing it's where he says
the best proof there's intelligent life
in outer space is the fact it hasn't
come here he says the fact we haven't
found the slightest evidence for life
much less intelligence beyond the spirit
does not surprise or disappoint me in
the least
our technology must still be laughably
primitive we may be like jungles savages
listening for the throbbing of tom-toms
well the ether around them carries more
words per second than they could utter
in a lifetime so you know he's it's kind
of tongue-in-cheek but but you know it's
also like you know the the the Groucho
Marx thing about he wouldn't belong to
any club that would have him as a member
you know I think it's something along
those lines of all why the hell are they
but you know monkey around with us
stupid shaved monkeys yeah so I mean
that that's an interesting retort to it
I don't think it completely addresses
the issue but it's a little bit of a
paradox there so let's talk about this
in his life so in 400 1917 his dad is
actually a way at the front because his
father was a farmer and the family was
running a boarding house at the time to
make ends meet his father doesn't
actually live very long he dies when
Clark is just 1314 he managed to buy a
farm and the farm was a catastrophe
things didn't work out the way they're
supposed to to go now Clark by this time
had already encountered science fiction
he was already doing a bit of writing he
talks about we talked about these great
pulp she was reading amazing stories at
that time
which I can't imagine could have had the
distribution in England that it had here
in the United States so I wonder how he
got his hands on that he graduated from
middle school and then goes to London to
try to find work in part because his
family needs the funds works as a
bureaucrat and doesn't nothing really
all that extraordinary is happening at
that time but then the war comes about
and he winds up becoming a radar
specialist he's a very smart guy and
does a lot of work there he gets
commissioned and then it publishes
before he's actually released from the
from the RAF he publishes his first
essay in wireless world magazine called
extraterrestrial relays and he releasing
a physicist mathematician engineer this
was about the idea something that we
take for granted now satellites that
remain in orbit and stay at the same
place and he was suggesting that you
could have a communication network this
is in 1945 he's suggesting you could
have geosynchronous satellites as a
communication network now some of this
is probably you know floating around at
the time but he's he's one of the people
who puts these ideas together he gets
released from the Air Force in 46 I
think a lot of people you know we often
think of like wartime ins V day and then
suddenly everybody is out of the
military but it doesn't actually work
like that like I know my grandfather was
stuck in the army until 1946 and I think
he had to do something to get out that's
not it so did Clarke yet await then he
receives a fellowship to King's College
and starts going there he is elected
president of the British and Planetary
Society and one of his first science
fiction stories is published in
astounding graduates extraordinarily
quickly
you must have plowed through the courses
you know with great speed he graduates
with honors and math and physics and
then he writes The Sentinel why is the
Sentinel in poems that have been a
dollop of hand the back story that one
that's one that Kubrick wants to adapt
later on that's that's what becomes 2001
yeah so he's writing this piece and you
can see it takes a long time to actually
get these these things to work out a
little bit later you notice that he
meets and marries this Marilyn may feel
that marriage did not work out and he
said he wasn't suited for marriage but
in point of fact he was actually gay or
in his view somewhere along the spectrum
he talks about you know I think he may
have been getting this from from some of
the sexologists at the time you know
this notion that there's like
heterosexual female heterosexual male
and sort of bisexuality in between and
he thought that just about everybody is
on it in this book actually in the
distant future anybody who's a hundred
percent heterosexual winds up being
viewed as potentially mentally
imbalanced well and having a weird
obsession I know well that's I mean that
is a little bit of a digression but you
know on the spectrum now it's like like
how many different planes are we
operating in you know and my kids will
inform me about new for Ian's tations
genders sexes that they hear about not
it's not in their school because they're
not teaching anything or well they like
that but from their classmates and from
popular culture so that Clark would
probably be you know really interested
in those what's going on at present in
terms of what was was not the sexuality
but the grounding
oh that what he was writing his [ __ ]
you seen he was projecting from one knew
about math and science yeah to what it
could be
and he was using real-life science to
project possible futures and that was
one of these that drew me to them when I
was young that was something I was gonna
bring up in the world building you know
one of the things sci-fi authors do is
have have possible things be actual in
their universe that they have some sort
of scientific basis right so you know if
you think about faster-than-light travel
space travel that that's that's an
important one if you want to have a big
universe out there that you can get to
different things and usually you know
when they're really bad science fiction
authors they just make something up
right you flip the switch or the
faster-than-light Drive works and you
know if it doesn't work well maybe you
got to fix the coils or something that
sounds like that right and then the
pretty good ones will try to come up
with some sort of seemingly rational
explanation but every time you pick at
it it winds up being just made-up stuff
and nonsense but at least they go like
to three levels again Clark is really
unusual in that he is trying to do as
much as he can to make it as realistic
as possible there's actually a story and
I think it may be by Philip dick where
there's these time travelers and they go
back in time to a sci-fi convention
because yeah that's right the sci-fi
authors were being viewed as as precogs
as people that pre comments yeah exactly
and so there's a story and I forget
exactly iminium I knew Theodore sturgeon
writes a story in which there's some
technological advance that the people in
the future need so they go back or their
time thing to kidnap him and get the
story and turns out unfortunately he's
drawn
can't cuz it looks good here yeah
service and they they're never you know
they never actually realized that he was
just making stuff up but but yeah Clark
is I mean the fast wasn't like tried
that he did that
you know the things that he describes it
here
they're pretty speculative but all the
other stuff is is connected as it
possibly could be to the science of his
time and he stays on top of every
scientific you know development that he
can attract so that's that's a good
point you know just like in here he wins
prizes you know typical sort of author
prizes a Hugo Award the Nebula Award he
becomes a sci-fi Grandmaster but he also
wins the Marconi award and he that's for
communication and I forget exactly what
the rest of the description was but they
had to do with his notion of using
satellites he's invited to be one of the
people with Walter Cronkite narrating
what's going on with the moon launch
that's you know kind of big stuff there
he testifies before Congress about the
remember the Star Wars or SDI initiative
he was in he was against that so he's
brought in and he's not just a sci-fi
author he's he's a reputable scientist
yes and I didn't put any of the done
finishing here some of the words that he
wins in there too are for for that that
popularization work and you know I'll
say something here too about
popularizing we often talk as if
reaching a popular audience is something
pretty easy to do you just got to take
the really complicated concepts there
and then explain them for ordinary
people and anybody can do that sort of
thing so there's a big drive right now
to have like public science it's really
hard to do very few people who can
up at that level can successfully talk
to an average person on the street and
make themselves understood in any way
whatsoever and that that doesn't just
apply to science that applies to history
a lot of great historians just cannot
explain there their topic adequately to
the average Joe philosophy big problem
you know I I don't want to get too much
on the soapbox about this but many of my
peers who teach just cannot reach their
students because they they can't bridge
that gap but he was really good at that
and that takes it probably takes
something sort of like maybe in a talent
but it probably also takes a lot of like
thinking well this example work or if
I'm saying this how could this be
misunderstood and that's really hard to
do when you know your your topic because
you're too close to it you can't tell
what somebody else would misunderstand
about it you know so there there's a one
of the awards in there the UNESCO thing
where is that yeah so that is
specifically for popularizing science
you know UNESCO is all about culture and
science by the way world philosophy day
coming up in November it's a UNESCO
thing every year they don't do a great
job and publicizing it's nothing we'll
be doing something here Milwaukee about
that you know if he you know for 48 yeah
I had a day job or used practicing
mathematician or in physics or working
in industry or academia or some other
than who's writing well he he as far as
I understand he made a lot from his
writing as a matter of fact he at the
time he was unusual in that he was a
ward of the three book contract when
nobody nobody in science fiction was
getting advances for
books in a row so I think you could do
that but he did take on you know things
here and there and when he moved to Sri
Lanka the money would go so much further
than anywhere else and then later on
he's got you know these television
programs that he's doing although those
are not those are not until Tulane you
know like 19 1980 mysterious world is
broadcast he would have had a lot of
residuals from 2001 as well but what did
was he doing from 48 to come on even I
mean his degrees or his majors in 48 he
was still thinking about soom he wasn't
taking literature literature something
he was thinking yeah Aspen physics guy
didn't know but yeah as a hobby where
does a hobby become good enough that it
has the income that you wanted yeah says
I don't need the day job I got a new day
job I'm a writer
well yeah I miss curiosity yes he's
already publishing in 48 that's his
first novel and he sold quite well you
know as when you when you read them
rereading these I was like you'd read it
and you'd be like top that I'm done with
that that's you could read through his
books pretty quickly it's kind of
surprising he didn't write much more you
know and then this is all of his novels
and collections of short stories that we
have there so does he talk about other
than economic so why would he live oh
well part of that had to do with his
sexual orientation laws against
homosexuality in Britain at that time
are pretty concerning I mean there were
a year to but there was a British felony
I would have thought they would have
mirrored no he was much it was a muscle
ization was kind of mixed there's
there's Hindus and Buddhists there and
that's part of what the conflicts what
it was about
yeah I mean you could
I mean I'll put it this way you could
get away with a lot more in British
politics that you could in Britain it's
up near wall see if you love culture
yeah then you know you have a long-term
business partners friend lover
we winds up being mayor buried next to
Nelson married next to it wasn't
possible but buried next to long after
he had died when Clark does he's buried
there and in Sri Lanka but he you know I
think it's not just about that he also
he knew that Sri Lanka is sort of a some
respects a gateway to these ancient
civilizations it's a great location he
also walked doing scuba diving and so he
would even do that he organised dives
with people until he then one of the
other things that happens in here he
contracted polio which was still you
know really a scourge at that time and
screwed up his lungs somewhat he didn't
have any of those sort of it was my 62
were you holy o vaccines thirty but he
didn't get it yeah well and and when he
was diagnosed with post polio syndrome
at first they thought it was something
else was I think white I'm blanking him
there was an initial diagnosis and then
and then they diagnosis that and he was
confined to a wheelchair you know it
screwed up as long as he ends up dying
later on of respiratory failure
but that's you know decades after that
he was also nominated for the Nobel
Peace Prize it at one time well yeah
what was the rationale there I mean for
a psycho out there that seems unusual
well just me the Peace Prize
no be smart you have to meet me for
trying to bring cultures to use
something about he was about service
about bringing peace yeah I mean he was
he wasn't politically active you know
what he said you almost got it so yeah I
mean you know it's not material changes
the nominations we need for people who
are you getting I mean well I think they
probably I don't know the prize things
worse but I imagine they probably had
way more nominations that I think we're
gonna go through a committee it was a
city knowing yeah he was active in terms
of not neutralizing space yeah he was
and he was a advocate of sort of
intercultural understanding so and I
think it makes sense he's he's knighted
eventually he goes you know the British
and a couple different Wars he can see
it's a few of them I don't pretend to
understand how all that stuff works
myself hi my field but you know he he's
very involved over the course of his
life with you know recent developments
and in sciences dies just in 2008 you
know 10 years ago so we've got somebody
who's almost a contemporary with us
we're looking at let's jump into the
world-building thing so you know we're
talking a little bit about how he is it
some respects of realist as opposed to
vant assist when it comes to all the
different developments that go into the
technology he wanted to make it as close
to the science that we have he goes
further and trying to explain the
scientific principles and age taking you
know you could say that his world has
its roots in the world that you and I
live in
it's just extrapolated you know maybe
sometimes a thousand years into the
future or
2001 we're already way past that right
he's got a few that are there later than
that in the series but it is it is the
world that we we know and it's just been
sort of built down narrative Li from
there so he's projecting him and
development further and then he you know
he brings up he makes up people who come
up with important ideas the way that
people like azimoff do or Heinlein you
know we're gonna have some names
associated with that well the things
that's really striking yeah I want to
see you guys read this think about this
is are there any characters in his book
that really in his books that really
stuck with you where you were like wow
that was really a full character arc
they were fully developed you couldn't
have the story without them they were
irreplaceable ends up being I mean I
think in Chavez and if you're gonna pick
two characters over the most central
would be the alien and the United
Nations secretary-general guy right
maybe the most important but but in a
certain way there is yeah they're kind
of replaceable he it's not like he gives
him short shrift he he tells you what
you need to know about the characters
and they have real lives they love each
other they hate each other they have
rivalries some of them die but he
doesn't spend a lot to develop and
critics with none of this they the one
set you know that
kind of anemic you know some have been a
bit more generous with that he was more
in ideas and it was characters yes that
says that I was trying to go back to
like with childhoods end it was you know
this forming this you know this
so-called peace but then if these people
just later on and did nothing after
other there's a peaceful but they just
lost like what it meant to be human
almost yeah you know and well then
there's the development of humanity
leaving what we know is well yeah and
then then you know second up all these
people so I said there's some like you
know ideas and even in the one I just
read more recently and it was wrong
about that that - I mean that that [ __ ]
like you said just just being there yeah
existing and no one knows why they know
it's there they you know some kind of
contact that there is no contact it's
just a presence yeah and then um and
then the second time it comes back then
they you know they have a little there's
some robotic kind of interactions but
then it is that with these characters
that stated it's almost you know gonna
create a new Eden sort of thing you know
they were gonna yeah start a whole new
culture on this ship because there was
nothing there so you I think you're
right it's the plot is not driven by
characters that's driven by problems and
ideas and I think you know in a way
that's probably harder to pull off isn't
right characters do we all relate to
them right and we relate to these
characters but we don't get sucked into
that more other like oh I wonder what
happen to him after this well the only
thing he had really cared miss was like
2001 with Dave and he'll you know this
yeah generations law yes yes
so what care 2001 yes several
generations Rama is several generations
yeah so the storyline goes beyond a
single character to develop yeah and you
know I'll say this too even does have
sort of a knack for making you feel the
jet
humanity of the characters like in the
end of songs of distant earth right
there's this guy and he's on the ship
that's got to keep on going and this
this sea world the washa he's got he's
like a child behind a fairway and he
realizes that by the time that he gets
to the place and they're able to
establish you know transmissions his son
will have his easygeeze grants to status
suspended animation
his son will have lived and died and
he'll never have known his son and it's
just a few lines but Clark is able to
convey all that all that pathos and
that's all I needs to do he doesn't
dwell on it you know they have the
situation anything like that and then he
just goes on with the rest of the story
so I think that's that's kind of unusual
for any kind of author I guess you know
the only people that we could think of
who do stuff like that maybe historians
write the idea of decisis nobody got the
entire generation that's been born and
died yeah well I think with with the
drama that we render with Rama I just
again trying to recall all that sacred
like six cross sunset um but there were
after the first encounter because
nothing was done they were just there
yeah and it just threw it just who chaos
into unto the Europe because they didn't
they didn't know how to deal with this
you know this thing was there
it didn't communicate he was just there
so other ideas of religion and all the
stuff just like went away because and
then and then they were dead this whole
there all the kind of economy collapsed
and then you took what another like 15
another generation to come back from
that to come back stronger than their
ship reappeared again and again did
nothing and then there were a couple of
but then then of course severe they were
gonna attack and try to blow it out of
that things go right war with you know
it was just the presence of the idea of
it rocked the whole world
called something again was like the the
great chaos sort of thing and it just
shut the whole you know yeah I mean that
goes back to that that issue that you
were talking about at the very start why
why do you want to have aliens showing
up because whether it's aliens or
whether it's their artifacts like a
giant you know [ __ ] that you don't know
what the hell it's for gonna leave
system off but you know everything you
believed in is now that they're so hot
that just shoots everything awesome
there's a everybody system says we are
the only thing yeah yeah I mean you know
some religions can adapt to that sort of
thing it's funny because he'll have like
the latter-day saints still around and
doing things you know it's not endorsing
them in any way but they're they're like
setting out their own colony ships and
things like that in tales of your songs
that just occurred so you get the idea
that some belief systems would have
enough permeability but it takes them
you know some real dancing around the
minikit work yeah
well let's talk about the mysteries
things that this does the laws this ties
him with his opponent so there's there's
a stream laws and we actually talked at
the very beginning of this series two
two-and-a-half years back about the
third law but the first law is is really
quite good what a distinguished but
other than the scientists state
something as possible he's almost
certainly right when he state something
is impossible
he's very probably wrong we tend to be
more conservative about
we think could possibly be the case and
there's actually a philosophical
precedent for this one tree to build
home liveness sue Clark you know knows
about one of the things that he would
often say is people are typically
writing what they affirm to be the case
and typically wrong in what they denied
to me when he was talking about
philosophers and and what what could be
you know possible and what couldn't be
possible they rule things out too easily
why do we do this well because it's
simplifies things for us right and then
of course distinguished but elderly
scientists part also thought that you
can't really do any productive work
after 50 years old as a scientist that
you should be like put out to pasture
you know the second law and this is for
a second I mean you know ease some you
know what would be you said if you use
it what's probable and improbable rather
than possible and impossible well I
didn't think when you say something is
possible it doesn't have to be a
distinguished every scientist yeah I
mean almost like isn't anything possible
I mean yeah so that's easy I think for a
lot of people say well of course but
when you say something's impossible yeah
you are sort of coming from on high is I
really got the world by handle look
maybe the religion survive something
like that are the ones who looked
impossible is the ones who declare the
impossible
there were narrow narrow things
something was declared is impossible is
like you know with with sort of what
would you call categorical necessity
only when you've got like a whole
apparatus of things that you you already
believe so you know in different
scientific paradigms in the past people
that say well this this can't happen or
this can't happen then you use the word
instead of probable then you might add a
disclaimer as far as we know it today
I mean you know he's not using which is
a big just
that's the reality one year so do you
mean like when somebody says something
is probable he is almost certainly
rightly says something that's improbable
no I'm saying yeah I'm saying the second
sentence maybe you can't fit with
improbable somebody says something is
that to say something is improbable he's
well certainly wrong I'm saying probable
is an important important different
level than saying it's impossible yeah
but I think it also is just like we
forget to say as far as we know today
possible sounds like forever though yeah
these are a whole different modalities
that's sort of a technical term for that
and you're right there are so many
things that are improbable as we know
today another thing that would kind of
go with is like conceivable or
inconceivable right people throw that
word that's inconceivable well one of
the things we think are inconceivable if
you look at them carefully and you can
probably all the other stuff that the
brain is sort of the hardware but then
it's like what what data do you have in
there if you were like operating in
terms of physics from say in the late
19th century there's a lot of things
that we now take for granted that they
would must be shocked by it's and then
that can't be the case I mean they
thought that that there was an ether
that waves went through and oh that's
just unbelievable I mean saying well
that's not the emotion yeah and we have
a friend who just says it all the time
and it's about politics
you know there's unbelievable but I mean
contrast that with probability and
possibility and then see unbelievable
it's a different standard right
with disunion Stanley is in the formal
logic or that's called the agility of
out there yeah judgment yeah nothing I
mean it's not believable
they don't believe it but it applies it
applies with my current body of
knowledge Who I am
yeah I believe not that I said no that's
possible or whatever I mean it just sort
yeah it's a more honest way of saying
something I don't well that's right and
you know one of the things that is
distinctive about the scientific
approach when it is general genuinely
scientific when it doesn't turn into its
own kind of like faith system is that a
thing should be open a challenge right
and you should surely show as many eyes
looking at it from as many perspectives
as possible and although ideally you
want to try to replicate things although
we've seen that we're in the middle of a
they call repre replicability crisis
when it comes to the social sciences
right all these great experiments turn
out not to be reproducible or they let's
just see it must be very careful it's
not that they aren't reproducible they
just haven't been reproducing well some
of them you've probably given the
standards of like informed consent and
changed some of them you couldn't do
epicly and get funding for you know
which means you need to let some other
country do that like you know
where they have looser standards that's
let's just talk a little bit about this
you know yeah
correlation of what we think about is
religion or belief in Valatie okay and
in the faith elder yeah that we're
accepting something that we don't have
hard time on Schwartz yeah I haven't got
evidence of the aliens I wish I had some
before I died
yeah Clarkson and then within how does
that fit with science fiction which the
audience and the writers are always
asked to extrapolate to sort of think
beyond to believe to make believe yeah
as if it's almost like accepting it on
faith you don't hide evidence but we are
extending our imagination because this
is a failure of imagination today that's
maybe causing a lot of our problems I
would say to two things about that one
one is that that Clark himself actually
has another core tonight I picked out he
thought that politicians should be
reading science fiction he says one of
the biggest roles of science fiction is
to prepare people to accept the future
without pain and to encourage a
flexibility of mind no he's doing with
his kind of science fiction right but he
says politicians should read science
fiction not westerns and detective
stories because he thinks that that sign
so this is you know science fiction
could actually have like a role in
changing behaviors the other thing I was
gonna say is so if you think about like
religious faith and then think about the
willing suspension of disbelief that s
it that curling fiction one of the big
differences is until fairly recently you
don't have too many people that are like
you know making decisions and running
their lives on the basis of what happens
in a sci-fi novel
whereas with religion you know people
they make huge decisions in the
instructions in life but think about
star wars and the fact that you've got
like this whole bunch of you know people
who identify with it and think that you
know somehow they're living like Jedi's
and and nobody really knows when
this stuff means because it's so
underdeveloped you know but there is
like now a Jedi religion made up
essentially out there but people claim
to practice and they run their lives
according to it you know unless they're
hypocrites right yeah yeah yeah but you
know I mean it's just it's interesting
and we take the science we have an
appeal to advocates or you know
audiences in science fiction yeah but it
quickly goes into this kind of
make-believe
where you're not going to extrapolate
you're not gonna open your mind and just
say okay there's two very strong in
faith in terms of a religious
perspective because it's fake because
it's like an insurance policy
Clark's out there were a couple
different answers to that and he
distinguished between different sorts of
religions one on one which so the
distinction comes up in this book he
talks about an alpha religion and alpha
gods and Omega the idea was that the
Alpha gods are like you know traditional
thing about Greek polytheistic guides or
you know like Jehovah the Bible or you
know the way a lot of people think of it
it's fundamentally based in an emotional
level against people the sort of things
you're talking about like sense of not
just identity for themselves but being
part of the community being part of a
tradition all those sorts of things and
it can the problem is he says well
there's too damn many of these gods and
they all say different things that's
what the hell are you gonna do right and
then you know what we're talking to it
when those guys is like or their
practice practitioners or laborers have
staked out positions on things like the
earth is flat well it turns out it's
round you're kind of screwed right now
the Omega religion that he talks about
this is sort of like a it's essentially
a humanism you know there is a
humanistic approach to religion out
there that you know looks at the cosmos
as being something that should inspire
us with wha and you know human nature
should and then you can even like argue
there there must have been some original
creator using these kind of methods
achill arguments but then God becomes
something more like an explanatory
principle you know another way of
articulating us Blaise Pascal made the
distinction between the God you say
about Christianity of course you talked
about the God of the Philosopher's that
be the Omega God and the God of Abraham
Isaac and Jacob the God of Revelation
God who intervenes in history and all
that sort of stuff and in this you know
like and this one where so this is
happening like couple millennia in the
future they're the Alpha religions of
all died out as a matter of fact when
they sent off these colonies they made a
deliberate choice not to send any
religious literature a lot and that also
meant getting rid of other literature
that refers to religion they say
Shakespeare so they they expunged all
that and then some things to these
people they'd actually saw the people up
they said that embryos out to these
these planets that eventually didn't
even send that they just sent genetic
profiles and then reconstituted people
there
they still have in Clarks here they
still have a need for something like a
divine but it's it's not it's not a
moment like the divine of the religions
of were used to does that make sense I
mean because he's more of a contemporary
Titan yeah or whatever I mean there's a
greater chance his his notes his
archives they're in good form I do you
have any idea what where those has been
that's a good question I don't know it
would be very interesting to me I mean
yeah if somebody got revealed or you
could go somewhere access some of these
things like how do you struggle with the
idea or not
you know 2001 what do you put into that
you know what an exam in Devon is did he
start with a little cheat sheet that say
okay I I'm gonna build after this book
and here's what I'm going to do oh and I
have to keep coming back I'm gonna keep
this book separate yeah yeah I mean his
archives would be in such good shape as
opposed to maybe 12 pins which is a lot
of letters going back and forth oh yeah
I mean it's but it
that's because Tolkien himself was a
careful guy there's some of the people
we've looked at we're kind of wild yeah
you're right but I think I mean somebody
whose mind is open that they start a
book and then they start wandering says
wait a minute I got to get a book out of
this so I better sort of we have some
notes for the next book you can keep
this one
I mean 2001 comes out of that story this
time that he had Kubrick are
collaborating back and this is 20 year
period or some of these I know they're
not in collaborate remember I mean yeah
this isn't published yeah I mean you
know crickets those like I think six or
seven year yeah there were and they're
bouncing ideas off of each other so that
was a bit of a different process than I
think other right let's talk about these
other laws so because this is a great
discussion but the only the second one
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture a little
way past them into the
impossible now if it's strictly speaking
impossible you shouldn't be able to
venture past the possible right but this
is how we find out people say well you
can't do that sort of thing and then
somebody is standing there saying oh
what was that you said
I think there's words you can insert in
there that would the same thing was a
problem a little way pass into what
people make Emily think of as impossible
yeah I mean yeah yes maybe that's what
you know yeah I mean you could you can
also say like you know people have had
these very rigid notions of what a good
human life is like and you could say
well so many ventures past that it shows
that a good light as possible over here
as well you know think about some of the
radical changes just in our own
lifetimes in terms of like gender roles
[Music]
that's right yeah alternate alternate
types of marriage structures amended
that you get the idea of some of those
guys who could be with Clark it wouldn't
[Music]
yeah now the third law this is one we've
talked about quite a lot any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
so we use this pass to talk about you
know like maybe there's the borderline
between sci-fi and fantasy is kind of
kind of porous but the way we couldn't
think about this is if we did encounter
aliens what they do might seem
miraculous to us or or just you know
totally beyond us and he he also added
another law in their reading computer
manuals about the hardware is as
frustrating as reading sex manuals
without the software I can't I don't
actually understand that how it's
supposed to work with what the software
is for sex manuals but that was sort of
a tongue-in-cheek rehearsing
[Music]
let's try to figure out with the analog
would be here manuals without the
hardware you can't do hands-on practice
yeah yeah so now he also talked about
mysteries and this ties it a little bit
with what you're bringing up before I do
with the probable improbable hey this is
coming from that that show that he did
in he sets up three kinds of mysteries
so the mysteries in the first kind are
something that was once utterly baffling
but now completely understood and he
brought up the example of rainbows you
know magnets would fit in there
radioactivity was one that he liked
because when you know it was first being
looked at
this is totally baffling and revise
their scientific theories in order to
make sense of it and then we've got
mysteries of the second case these are
things that are today unexplained but
potentially explainable on some future
day like UFOs you know could turn out
that they really were aliens the whole
time could turn out it really was
weather balloons we don't know
mysterious creatures like yetis or
sasquatches you'll see this it's the I
don't know where it starts so I think
another football teams all day it was
something that was something Rosalie
during the logging periods of there was
a journalist yeah it was a state that
was out there and it just kept taking on
these these and they have always tell
more stories yeah yeah North we would go
through wine Lander and we always that
was like one of the stopping points cuz
this great big billboard one where the
whole day it was this giant looking it
was half a reptile with a big unicorn
horn and these I mean it was just you
know compilation of nonsense
yes it's just a compilation of nonsense
and and it is one of those tales of
Wisconsin yes yeah for mine it was
mainly done by the loggers okay so the
mysteries of the Third Kind all right he
says phenomena so bizarre and
inexplicable a conventional explanation
may never be found and he says there
there's no general agreement they even
exist so you may remember back in the
70s there were actually shows about
spontaneous human combustion people are
very worried about it nobody knows what
the whole idea that was there they never
figured anything out about that there
was never any consensus about it
poltergeists you know the ghosts exist
you know we're probably never gonna know
how many and this other thing mysteries
is the 0k and he says the only mystery
being how anyone was stupid enough to
believe them in the first place so the
Bermuda Triangle was it was one pyramid
power I don't know if you guys know what
that was there was have the thing back
in the it's really it is really really
well it's great I mean if you don't like
have a little pyramid and like you could
put your your stuff in there and this
must be transmuted and transformed and
if you lived inside a pyramid and fix
your body and stuff so Clark really
didn't have any he didn't feed him like
that sort of stuff at all
[Music]
it's still there okay it's still there
because there's a guy who built spirit
he's living in a pyramid
Oh more power to him I guess really yeah
I suppose if you're gonna build a
pyramid
you should statue that make it you know
to it up right you know so that was
built around that time back in the like
20s 30s
70 70 yeah okay why was it was popular
way back before that - like Chesterton
writes about some of this no sir well
just just to just to put a little kink
in here there was a program that was out
a few years ago it was called fringe and
I'm in the show the show yeah that was
based on the spontaneous combustion that
was based you know there it was friction
but it was based on scientific cycling
stuff was going on at the time you
improve a lot of these things and some
of this stuff was actually in the word
yeah and that's why they called it you
know there was a fringe element like
this could happen under these
circumstances sort of things so again
this may be in that realm of possible
that we haven't hit yet with his and I'm
quite understanding about whether or not
you can actually blow up you know
whatever
well I remember there was a lot of
concern about like I remember like my
grandma in particular being you know
worried that that a one of us could
could burn up learning to preach there
was a way but I don't remember all
family I only watched the first season
of that oh well I like anything that's
crazy so I got I was you know there's
nowhere else in the Bronx or something
else oh yeah I remember that one - that
was a sci-fi show yeah let's talk about
evenings
since we're bringing up all this stuff
so Clark a/c is right and you know I
think about how he depicts them they are
the ones that we encounter at least or
or fail to encounter Rhonda drama
there may be on us that so there's this
notion of like technology as being sort
of you know indistinguishable from magic
whether they're trying to bring us into
something so we've got you know 2001
we've got this monolith and it's great
just you know discussion of the ape guy
who has no idea what this is but it
starts giving him ideas and flooding his
mind with images and sort of takes kick
starts human development and then
there's this idea that Clark is playing
around with that we have to be brought
up to their level so we're not fully
rational yeah we haven't fully developed
our full capacities and it's interesting
with transcend yeah I mean the Indians
are beyond waiting the hell beyond us
but they've reached their endpoint
they're never going to develop any
further and become part of this super
mind that the human beings are but it's
a really you know as I was reading it
it's those last bits have been a really
melancholy quite sad and you think about
what would it be like to be the last
human beings not just in the sense of
like a massive catastrophe happening
like you don't see these zombie shows or
yeah knowing that your children it's not
like they there's an intergenerational
gap and they can't relate to you like
children have trouble relating to their
parents and they're you know like
correcting that and saying we don't we
use words to mean this they're almost
like a different species you know what
would it be like to lose your kids to
that sort stinked basically just yeah
yeah but I thought Joe is in the more
poignant piece was the aliens who know
they can
oh yeah they played the role of
nursemaids yeah incubator people they
operate the incubator there are the
races that can make the leap but they
can never do it themselves yeah they
should watch all these other races eces
from other planets make that leap and
they know they will never get there yeah
I mean for me personally I don't think I
would want to be part of some sort of
Overmind like that so I think I'd rather
be one of those aliens but yeah they're
in contact with it all the time and
they're serving it for millennia species
after species after species so this is
very you know melancholy booked by the
end of it
rendezvous with Rama I mean it you could
say it's a whole different emotion like
surprise and then what curiosity no
alderman what the hell is this thing
supposed to be
[Music]
yeah right here you know that that's one
thing the aliens do provoke fear when
they do show up on the part of human
beings so there's this you know that's
interesting you just need to like try to
keep things managed and secret in
child's attendance is the UN and the
aliens that are managing everything
they're keeping it secret right
in 2001 the governments don't want to
reveal right away exactly what they've
uncovered because it could lead to mass
panic yeah yeah so that that's actually
a good lead-in to discussion about
religion that we already had quite a bit
of but you know Clarke said it may be
that our role on this planet is not to
worship God but to create the greatest
tragedy
mankind's entire history maybe the
hijacking of morality by religion the
ration certian God made man in his own
image is ticking like a time bomb at the
foundations of many faiths and as the
hierarchy of the universe is disclosed
to us we may have to recognize this
chilling truth if there are any gods
whose chief concern is man they cannot
be very important gods so that there'd
be like higher gods and gods that would
be concerned with us Clark is a humanist
he thinks that you know there there are
some useful elements of religion but
they're mostly things that could be
stripped out of it and then you could
have that the purified form then leave
all the traditional faiths yeah yeah he
mentioned songs of just an earthworm
that you talk about they get out further
out and they still create religions in a
way yeah really you could say there's a
sense off these things that's right but
there's no like there's no worshipping
this fetish or something
well here's I could be of William James
oh yeah the varieties of religious
asperities religious experience in 1901
and then she was lecturing it in girl
yeah it's the different lectures the
traditional issues and he he began
lectures by saying you want to answer
the question of is there God yeah does
man meet God and he ended the lectures
by saying man needs something bigger
than himself
yeah yes yes God will there will always
be a need for God because man were
always mean unless you're also except
philosophical and psychological things
yeah man well his view was man will
always need something bigger than
himself
look to keep yourself in money no not so
much
it's just too well yeah Clark has this
other thing where he's talking about
healings and
says he says two possibilities exist
either we're alone in the universe
forward both are equally terrifying you
know because if there is something some
god there's a guy in the classic sense
that odds are we probably given a
plethora of different orientations we've
probably done the wrong thing well so
we're probably all screwed except for
you know whatever group over here I
actually had though the right answer but
he doesn't think that is or maybe there
is you know super-powerful aliens in
which case how do we relate to them what
do we make of that or it's just us and
the cosmos then where do we take our
barrels from yeah and some of the
humanists response to this as well we
sort of try to realize what's best in
human nature it's gradually strip away
all the crap all the stuff that's been
holding us back but you know you can
reach sort of evolutionary dead ends
doing that where you don't you don't
have any greater challenges left and you
just kind of stagnate and then people
you know crave some sort of excitement
yeah let's talk about the this notion of
moral or ethical development that he
really does value to this and he says as
our neural species is in the process of
proving one cannot have superior science
and inferior morals the combination is
unstable and self destroying that that
unless we know there's a lot of other
people who sent us they included some
religious people you see quite a lot of
perspectives saying we've got this
massive increase in technology and the
resources that it affords us and we
haven't changed who we haven't change
who we are as human beings to become
better than
and so it becomes quite terrifying
Gabrielle Marcel talk samosas being at
the Despres of our own technics so he he
phrases the things that we thought would
make our lives better they take over our
lives but you know some moral or ethical
development what is this tink it's
definitely for Clark not just a matter
of getting better information you know
like you can't just like put text books
in everybody's hands about how to be a
good person they're all gonna you know
improve I mean if you might do that it's
more about like changing the social
structure and gradually changing the
mores or the fundamental ways of seeing
things you know and you could think
about where progress has been made in
our lifetimes you know in the last
however many years you know what more is
changed some some things that you know
are little trivial I actually think it's
a good thing that there's this emphasis
at least here in our you know schools
and preventing bullying right because I
remember when I was a kid yeah it was
everywhere everybody got there I won't
say everybody got bullied because there
were the bullying doing it and there
wasn't much that was done about it
you're just told suck it up or you know
get over it
and made a lot of people pretty
miserable and and you know we do have a
culture now that maybe swung a little
bit to the other extreme where anything
can get labeled bullying a little bit
too easily but maybe it is progress to
do not have kids so so worried about it
damaged by you know I came out okay but
that's because I was kind of big and
tough you know I saw a lot of kids who
really screw them up and so that might
be a sigh an example of what Clark is
the viewing as is moral progress you
don't change that just by having public
service announcements hey don't bully
you know
remember those after-school specials you
know that cool tabouli you've actually
got to like do things to change the the
social structure and that requires a lot
of time and actually just been happening
over the course of civilization we're
getting even though it seems like we
have a lot of violence we're getting a
lesson that's fine yeah we're walking
down the street just stab each other
anymore like and that didn't happen
during them they just I mean it
literally did and I mean we have been
developing an ethic I think as some of
our our technology and science develops
so we have to say just because we can
should wait you know I mean like with
the atomic bomb yes we can but then we
just after we drop this table should we
just continue this because I mean and
and now with the idea with cloning and
other different things just because we
can should we and I think along the way
we have been developing as we're
evolving or whatever else or moral and
ethic is to some extent yes you always
it was all liars but I think as a
population we are continually part of it
is we we when it comes to these
developing like new technologies we kind
of get taken along for the ride by
whoever is willing to throw in the money
to do them and there isn't quite enough
like public debate about it deliberation
experimentation Oh money in power get
the money in the power behind you you
don't have the grants you don't have the
research money you don't want the
staffing yeah you know for Sciences
particularly there could be something
important we should be don't worry but
if you can't get the money and the power
behind you you can't do it but I think
we still push a lot of stuff out there
just to see what happens and until it
gets really bad I mean look it up I mean
you talk about bullying but yeah reason
there's orchestrated programs today like
maybe never
of course because social media is so
empowered bullies yes of all sorts that
it's worth it's probably working hours
today than it was before they had
programs but I guess I just think n it's
it's money and power but we feel this I
mean look at the whole social media
thing all this you know vending monies
and announce people yeah how did we you
know we let the corporation's who make
the money in this sort of self control
probably that's not going to work for a
while just yeah actually but what is the
role the government no because we have
free speech and you know there's a big
debate about whether we should consider
things like say Facebook or Twitter to
be something analogous to public
utilities yes yeah yeah they have it
there there's definitely there's
something more if I'm get the truth is
yeah we understood as opposed to let
anything fly go back to those Eagles I
think it's somewhat develops over just
the curse of self-preservation you know
because they so many times they people
say well you know atheists or humanists
don't have they're not good people
because they don't have a religion and
then it was talked about well actually
it isn't religion that keeps people from
not doing harm
it's it I don't harm you you don't harm
me it's part of self-preservation so you
know it isn't based on any religious
thing it's just based and if you can get
along better in society it's gonna be
better for you
so I mean then now that when they came
we're bringing this back to that we tend
not to to steal and murder not because
some guy tells us to us just because we
don't want that happening to us so we
form a society that's based on more
self-preservation and somebody like hark
would see that as part of the basis for
a rational morality but it would take
some of the elements and I keep showing
up in his books are similar to a couple
different movements in ethics one of
them is you you know you guys Marv
Albert Schweitzer right he remember
corks that were all concerned
this this ethical ideal of reverence for
all life and that's a tough thing to
pull off you know he was so adamant
about it like you know he's digging
holes for crops he'd like reach in there
and pull the spider out so it wouldn't
get buried things like that they do that
yeah yeah I take bugs outside I don't
swap yeah Hindu system was it James
don't even oh yeah yeah the notion about
the human violence and stuff and I think
you see some of these characters of
doors very very strongly the sort of
universal reverence for life but there's
also you know when you get them under
like having to make decisions where
somebody is going to get somebody's
gonna get hurt somebody's interests are
gonna be contravened I think Clark is
kind of utilitarian and utilitarians
look to trying to create the greatest
good for the greatest nighter even if
there are some negative outcomes for for
some people but you see his characters
at least some of them being very very
conscientious about this and so I think
what he's doing there is he's trying to
provide us with a model for how how we
could be reasoning through our problems
and situations you know and you'd have
to do a lot of your rational people
right because we're living in a time
where many people aren't whether they're
religious or or not people can be
motivated can be totally atheist and
motivated by the bottom line and you
know making as much money as possible
and ruin things for everybody in their
community but you you have to be able to
deal with those people in one way or
another and somehow corral them in so
you see his political leaders always
trying to produce something like a
consensus irrational consensus you know
but I wonder if anybody asked Arthur
Clarke before you died yeah to reflect
back on these many books published and
unpublished and to say what is it that
you
Turkish now what have you transall
wherever you transitioned the
enlightened people who read your books
yeah yeah what if what is if you
transform what did you want to see
transformed what have you have you built
something like a community well yeah I
mean yeah I wonder if that's in his
final goodbye video I haven't watched it
I don't get the interest yeah yeah that
could also be like you mentioned it
could be in this paper so just because
he's Morgan different he's you know you
so yeah bringing up some of these ideas
you know and this is we're really going
to struggle with in our lifetime to do
his work we were some big changes that
you know this is good watching quite for
the last big theme you know technology
robots artificial intelligence and also
automation what is it
what does it do you know the characters
in even this one which is probably just
rats they don't they don't trust the
robots all that much they don't give it
up too much autonomy okay Hal 2001 is
kind of fun to to read it I found it way
more fun to read them to watch the movie
and if you guys are fans visual images
leaving it wasn't overly verbal I mean
intentionally you wanted to stimulate
the electro-stimulation and it's true
yeah yeah yeah his mutants you know what
look it's a small shop yeah
you did it so you didn't give the
explanation watching mm water whose
impression that's what you only said
yeah I think a really good director like
him as being a co-author I mean that's
me yeah so my ID is made of his own you
know we get a lot more from the because
so when you're reading that when you're
reading hell and you're seeing like the
processes and the guy talking about his
suspicions of how that's going on this
sort of cat-and-mouse game that they
start playing with each other you
realize that you know Clark was Clark is
pretty optimistic about technology for
the most part but he also is at into the
notion that if we create a eyes they
could go off kilter just as much as
human beings so that that's I see the
bigger threat of automation or those
types of things is just sort of cutting
no no just basic meaning of life and a
purpose which you revolved in America
maybe now the world around work yeah you
know that work is a primarily validation
of the individual and their worth yeah
and you take away all need for work a
lot of it you know
and now I said like whoa what is my
meeting purpose what am i contributing
you know I mean do I need to have a
single run do I need to have these other
thing I just need the momentary thrill
of whatever I'm gonna get with lace yeah
whether you what it's really all the
work I know so I don't see the threat of
automation and robots and artificial
intelligence it's just been validated
the meaning and purpose of people's
existence and when that thing is taken
away well then where they're where they
get into because yeah there's no guiding
principle anymore that is that is a big
that is like blooming of horizon and our
current sort of political apparatus is
totally unequipped to talk about this
because they're the answer on both
Democrat and Republican side pretty much
all of our problems we're gonna create
more jobs the problem is the street it's
not as if it's false it's that having
that discourse takes up the space where
we could be like thinking out what the
hell are we going to do you know I'm
just like burning everything now if we
can do it should be yeah they run - okay
we've developed our digital tell us who
developed the robots we have to program
them yes to tell them what to do and
there's a there was an episode in Doctor
Who a couple seasons ago where they go
to a planet and there's no people it was
supposed to be deeper and you try to
figure out why there's no people and
there are these robots yeah little bit
redundant right you know the robots were
programmed to make sure he was happy
someone dies someone yeah because all
the nuance in there and there's a lot of
nuances
yeah see that's the problem hell yeah
you know that's so that's one of the
issues though is maybe someday in the
future we will have an AI that can
actually ask itself holy [ __ ] how did
things get to this point what the hell
is going on here right and have that
kind of reaction but for now they can't
right so whatever whatever they've got
going on there - yeah they proceeded
down that line whereas we human beings
we can like totally screw things up and
then like some of us can actually look
at each other
what oh yeah this can't go on like this
and that's something that I don't know
if we can actually program its
artificial intelligence you know again
that's one of those possibilities down
the road were that they can start
replicating and doing other things that
you know yeah where they start and then
now they can I mean they're greater than
the things that they're great at yeah
you know and I know people for instance
in the medical fields were very worried
about some of the AI advances and like
imaging and Diagnostics you know I mean
everybody is basically at some point of
that book the author adjustment to that
just talked about and then they are
talking about this in Davos and then
these big economic summits because
they're saying what the holding you do
with all these people because they know
there are any years down the road it's
going to be this and it's not just going
to be the people work in fact or is this
gonna be just supply everybody because
you know where it's gonna read it worst
is actually in the developing world
because most of those tasks that people
are dependent on for earning a living
can be automated very easily and they
they have weaker social structures and
legal structures that makes it easier to
bring them in so well there's a
cognitive dissonance you talk about
including later what we're going to do
jobs yeah but the way people look at
that they people think in terms of jobs
like water yeah yeah not yeah I know not
in terms of where this is going yeah
and those jobs are going to go away no
matter what yeah
there are jobs that are underway it
doesn't matter what we think they're
going to go away because it's eventually
the automation technology things are
going to make it not practical for that
job because this yeah but when you say
that to people about jobs they don't
think that way
they think in terms of the job my
father's always had a job I aspire to as
far as education is gonna get them out
of this hole I mean that's true
education is a proxy for jobs because
they're all my doctors other things are
going to even these high end jobs they
will eventually be released and I mean
this is what these two fellas were
talking while with this book on the
jobless economy and and they were kind
of saying to like what we gonna do with
all these people because you you have to
do something and they said it might go
back to almost like a makers system you
know where you're just really are their
sins and Barberie they're all that
nothing usually the best case yeah
that's the best case scenario where
you're not just hitting each other over
the head for your resources yeah but
more fun to do right or maybe they
thought that that it might almost revert
to something like that which is just
mind boggling no ease we get you as such
a technological state that we go back to
almost the middle age type book of
making and bartering in artists it may
be another alternative is it's a tough
sell I think and I say that she has an
educator continuing education you know I
mean there's there's a lot of people who
if they didn't have to work for a living
again for the beats let's say we have
this technological post-scarcity society
they would just like you know study
things all they want but that's not most
people I don't think you know and then
the question is how do you how do you
get people I think there's probably
there's probably something never would
be interested in that and they'd much
rather just you know I don't bang on
vending machines or do whatever right
and then there's the social media yeah
then there's the core people
love to you know to get an education and
sometimes they can't do it now the
others I think a big spectrum in between
where they could be steered that way and
the key question that I think most
educators are probably not able to
answer is how do you get them how do you
move that group again to valuing
education because just saying all I need
a ssin is a good thing that doesn't
change anybody's views you know or yeah
then you can't you don't have the the
possibility of holding out jobs in front
of them well if you do some job
retraining and get some education you'll
have a job waiting for it that is an
option so it's it's a really different
world between between climate change and
blanket area it is a real different
world that we're getting into the next
decades this work at this is you of work
being important yeah and we're not doing
anything to change how people think
about work because people get identities
from their job I think a single
self-worth and all kinds of things from
it you could say there's been if we
think about like the whole culture is
like one big you know sort of the city
right there's been changes in this
borough or in this borough over here but
there's nothing connecting than that you
know we don't have we don't have
institutions that are like saying well
what are we going to do with people how
are we gonna not train them for new jobs
but train them for new leisure you know
but in the meantime yeah metaphor is
seeing work you know or yes we feel
insecure and threatened whether if we
focus on people of color or whatever but
house yd is I'm no longer prepared for
today let alone the future I mean
they're not saying that it's a mental
always feel if they know where she comes
they're there for this back to just say
yeah I'm on something however they feel
that way but part of what they're old
are never gonna get but that doesn't
mean they don't take an oil changes
coming in behind the shirt that doesn't
you know that it scares people
no it's very she can't identify it they
don't know how to cope with it and and
they know what's coming
well it's introspective it's a zero-sum
game but if you gain I lose right really
true yes right yeah if if a group of
people games and economy then that must
mean it's coming from me and a lot of
the resentment is no longer at the if
stage it's because you but it also goes
back I think that when people they don't
want to learn because learning means
you're insecure oh they have to be age
18 or 20 or whatever yeah and I learned
enough I got enough don't upset that
just let me make the money I deserve and
so when you want me to relearn something
or up learn something or fiction or
whatever else it is that's more
threatening because it should be like
sort of those good old days what I
already know work for my dad my mom
should work for me but it's not so I
know the wall you know I'm gonna say no
more I just want people that are self
justifying my entitlement those [ __ ] and
it's happening we can't do anything
about it it's gonna keep moving forward
there's no I think we don't know well I
mean everything everything is moving
forward everything is going towards
whatever and and we're it's a one step
forward two steps back she steps forward
one step back
and people can feel it they just can't
identify it so let's just feel it's it's
scary well maybe part of what we need is
is discourse is about that that sort of
thing but the trick is to actually get
that into the public square though
oh there's such a pile of stupid out
there oh my gosh I mean it's just shock
to be certain times I you know every day
I just kind of look for the biggest
piece of stupid that I can hear and then
then I look for the funny thing and very
searching my house - sometimes it's
funny - oh it's all well it starts off
funny but then it ends up being very sad
that I'm pissing water views will reduce
some discussions like yeah but it's
always like I'm preaching to the choir
people who are not able to deal with it
we need to be thinking you need to be
talking they can't use the trick - like
they're not going to go if you tried to
talk to them they can hear it won't rain
you try to give them just a popular like
yeah we're not you know we're willing to
talk about my people who read science
fiction are a little more over to begin
with because you're open to that realm
of possibility that this is even right
so your mind is a little more open then
you know somebody who's out or not
reading at all that's true
well let's close on that because I know
they're gonna kick us out here the
standard out there though
you
[Music]